you support cops and troopers
not according to these party poopers
over the weekend that's saturday and
sunday
euphoria star sydney sweeney posted pics
and videos of her mom's 60th birthday
bash on her instagram account
much like my hot tub petting zoo
it was a cowboy themed affair
stu varney looks great in chaps molly
you were right
but liberal losers looking for reasons
to be grieved quickly got angrier than
julie banderas spilling a fresh drink on
her toddler
next time julie just leave the brat in
the car
or in the bar yes
no one's laughing at that
why
make jokes about kids and alcohol we've
crossed the line
anyway they called out the underdog
identified man in the picture wearing a
t-shirt with an american flag and a thin
blue stripe in the middle of course it's
a simple gesture showing he supports
cops but in their eyes he's a no-good
low-life racist and everyone else at the
party is two the online mob also didn't
like the red baseball cap some guests
wore that apparently said make 60 great
again
what does that mean as you know 60 is
the smallest number that is the sum of
two odd primes in six ways
and in the laws of judaism 60 is the
proportion of kosher to non-kosher
ingredients in a mixture of kosher food
in a word hitler
yes sidney addressed it tweeting you
guys this is wild and innocent
celebration from my mom's milestone 60th
birthday has turned into an absurd
political statement which was not the
intention please stop making assumptions
well i can relate nothing ruins a party
faster than an absurd political
statement like when i invited nancy
pelosi to strip at my bachelor party
the first thing she took off was her
face
[Laughter]
molly what's going on we were talking
about this for why are people getting
mad at birthday bashes they aren't even
invited to i was thinking that maybe
paul pelosi is the one you'd want to
party with more than nancy seems to know
how to have a good time just don't let
him i am sick of this though like this
just looked like a fun party it looked
like people were having a good time
um most americans would look at this and
just say it's fine but we are seeing
this thing where there this is like
element on the left that is completely
totalitarian they don't want people to
have fun they want to control everything
they want to control every aspect of
hollywood and they don't want people to
think for themselves and they don't
really want republicans or anyone who's
tolerant of republicans to be free to
enjoy themselves but uh it's a good
point but i i coined this phrase it's
called the uh what is it called target
expanding
target expanding demolition
which is where you just like i you just
now that you're wearing red the cap is
red you must be for trump so they just
keep expanding the definition definition
of demonization yeah she made a mistake
though mistake is not having fun and
partying it's that when the psycho left
started to raise problems about this i
saw the quote was don't make assumptions
like when you have family members that
have a make 60 great again red hat on
they probably voted for trump that's
cool just lead into it a little bit or
if you want you can take a page from a
left wing playbook and just say we're
calling in the fbi to investigate we
have no further comment until then
if you
see people it works every time yeah hold
on everybody we're calling in the fbi
james comey himself will weigh in on
whether this party had some republican
situation going on and then in three
days you know they're gonna like raid
the former president's house or
something crazy is gonna happen and
nobody will remember that's how it goes
julie generally you spend your uh
birthdays drinking alone in a car
in the parking lot of walmart
so does this ever sporting goods it's
pretty good
does this pose a problem for you what do
you make of this well i actually think
it's interesting because during the
height of the black lives matter
protests in the summer of 2020 she
actually tweeted in support of it so
it's interesting how they have a double
standard right like did they actually
make a an effort to look back into her
history because she fully supported
black lives matter but god forbid you
have a blue stripe in your shirt you
must support police therefore you must
want them to kill black people i don't
understand how the parallel comes
through but it doesn't surprise me jim
have you ever uh attended a themed party
that went back that was not good yeah
but
what's boggling to me is
how did who's watching first of all the
last thing i'm looking at is for a guy
in the background with a blue
blue and striped shirt i mean yeah
there's a lot to look at right there
[Laughter]
and
and just as a society
um when we're at the point there's no
other way to hide it it is
we understand your had a private owned
party
and one of the members owns for wearing
your own red hat
and the flag representing owns police
officers
don't you know we are defunding somebody
and we're here for your species
whoever commented
our pigs yes
get back in your stall there you go
i didn't know you could do irish people
too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else